pull de circonstance nous allons parler des femmes
des femmes d'aujourd'hui des femmes de l'antiquité
grecque de leur destin vraiment très enviable cette
vidéo aurait pu avoir pour titre aux origines du
slut shaming mais bon vous connaissez ma réticence
face au titre dit [ __ ] la sexy catch provoquant
de rêve de toute façon à chaque fois qu on
cherche un terme qui évoque le désir on raccorde
toujours au féminin heureusement aujourd'hui on
a quelques outils pour à la fois se faire plaisir
et communiquer avec les autres sans tomber dans un
discours culpabilisant et disqualifiants notamment
cette application que je vous présente aujourd'hui
puis jour qui sponsorise d'ailleurs la vidéo pure
et comme une plateforme avec des annonces en ligne
où les gens partagent le type d'expérience qu'il
recherche pure est une application de rencontre
pour explorer sa propre sexualité d'une manière
ludique sur est honnête et briser quelques tabous
au passage je vous conseille d'ailleurs de regarder
leur compte instagram si vous voulez essayer
cette application de rencontre mais que bah
vous avez peur de mal faire peur d'être mal poli
dans vos sollicitations et c'est en fait vous
allez trouver une sorte de coach du consentement
via cette application parce que même si c'est
une application de rencontre les règles du vivre
ensemble et de la loi tout simplement s'applique
alors vous allez voir que la vidéo qui suit montre
qui n'est absolument pas question de ça dans
l'antiquité oubliez le consentement et la liberté
on va voir que les relations sont la plupart du
temps très inégales en deux laissant la place
à des fantasmes masculins les femmes sont bien
souvent un instrument dans les mains des hommes
pour leur prestige ou leur plaisir alors les
nude de l'époque si vous voulez on les retrouve
sur les céramiques 1 et on n'est clairement pas
dans le partage mais plutôt dans la soumission
donc on peut se réjouir aujourd'hui d'avoir à
disposition des moyens techniques qui laissent la
liberté d'exposer la diversité des désirs donc
je vous invite à découvrir Pure App si ça vous
tente et puis bah on enchaîne sur le sujet du jour
On a déjà tout dit de la Grèce antique.
L’architecture, la philosophie, la démocratie,
la mythologie… et je m’y suis collée d’ailleurs.
Des milliers de livres d’histoire ont été écrits
sur cette civilisation, et le Ve siècle
av. J.-C. est souvent cité comme un
merveilleux âge d’or. Depuis plusieurs siècles,
l’analyse des très nombreux textes conservés a
permis de connaître dans les moindres détails
l’histoire grecque antique. Récits de guerres,
réformes politiques, résultats de
concours sportifs, traités scientifiques,
déroulement de cérémonies religieuses, tout
nous apparaît avec la plus grande clarté.
A un petit détail près : la vie des femmes.
Car quand on veut parler des femmes du passé,
on est tout de suite confronté à une difficulté de
taille, c’est le manque de sources. Les femmes des
périodes anciennes n’écrivent pas. Pour la Grèce,
on a bien quelques fragments de poèmes de Sappho,
mais c’est tout. Quelques centaines de mots
tout au plus. Faire une histoire des femmes
revient donc à essayer de déceler dans les
propos des hommes, des informations plus ou
moins idéalisées sur leurs mères, leurs filles,
leurs épouses ou leurs maîtresses. Ajoutons à
cela que les historiens jusqu’au milieu du XXe
siècle étaient presque uniquement des hommes,
donc pas forcément sensibilisés à la question, et
vous obtenez une absence totale de connaissances
sur la moitié féminine de la population.
Même si
l’histoire des femmes est longtemps restée
une sous-discipline de l’histoire généraliste,
pensée comme masculine, aujourd’hui, l’étude
des rapports entre hommes et femmes a souvent
sa place dans les livres d’histoire. On va
donc laisser de côté les hommes, pour une
fois, et essayer de cerner, entre les lignes,
le quotidien des femmes de l’Antiquité grecque.
Puisqu’il y a 2500 ans, les femmes grecques
n'écrivaient pas, lorsqu’elles sont mentionnées
par les sources, elles le sont avant tout en
précisant leur relation aux hommes. De manière
générale, les femmes sont le support de trois
types de relations. Elles donnent des héritiers,
des alliances sociales, ou du plaisir.
La première et la deuxième fonction sont
confondues dans une institution spéciale, le
mariage, tandis que la troisième fonction est,
on le verra, souvent distincte.
Le mariage est en fait un acte entre
deux hommes, par l’intermédiaire d’une femme.
C’est une alliance entre le père et son gendre,
qui se mettent d’accord sur une dot, c’est-à-dire
sur le prix du mariage. C’est aussi un acte public
qui concerne la cité car l’objectif du mariage est
la procréation légitime de nouveaux citoyens. La
femme stérile est ainsi considérée comme inutile,
incapable d’accomplir sa fonction première.
La maternité est en effet une obligation
pour l’épouse de citoyen. C’est une manière
de sécuriser sa position puisque l’absence de
descendance peut conduire l’époux à la répudier
pour prendre une autre épouse. Mais donner
naissance est un moment particulièrement
dangereux, nombre de femmes n’y survivent pas.
Euripide fait dire à Médée dans la tragédie du
même nom, qu’il est préférable de monter au combat
que d’accoucher. Et cette analogie entre combat
et accouchement est parfois faite de manière
officielle. A Sparte, les seuls habitants qui ont
le privilège de voir inscrire leur nom sur leur
sépulture sont les hommes morts au combat et les
femmes mortes en couches. L’enfantement est donc
la mission civique de la femme, l’élement central
de la condition féminine en Grèce antique.
Pour remplir cette mission, les filles sont
mariées très tôt, à peine adolescentes.
L’âge minimal semble être autour de douze
ans même si Aristote par exemple recommande
un mariage aux alentours de dix-huit ans pour
éviter que les grossesses trop précoces ne
soient mortelles. A partir de leur mariage,
les femmes ne connaissent plus que la maison
et leur mari. Le fourneau et le métier à
tisser sont bien souvent leur seul horizon.
La cuisine et le tissage constituent en effet
l’occupation par excellence de l’épouse.
L’activité du tissage est d'ailleurs très
souvent utilisée sur les décors céramiques pour
symboliser les activités féminines. La naissance
d’une petite fille à Athènes est même signalée
par la suspension d’un brin de laine au-dessus
de la porte du foyer. Une manière de rappeler ce
qui l’attend plus tard. C’est une tâche répétitive
et fatigante qui nécessite de nombreuses
étapes : nettoyage de la laine, cardage,
peignage, filage puis enfin tissage de l’étoffe.
Seule la teinture est confiée à des spécialistes
et réalisée en dehors du de la maison.
Nourrir le foyer n’est pas non plus une
mince affaire. Le traitement des grains stockés
dans les réserves est long et pénible. Grillage,
mouture, pétrissage, cuisson… la femme qui
pétrit le pain est dans les textes, un leitmotiv
de l’épouse dévouée. Les hommes ne s’occupent
de cuisine que pour les sacrifices religieux,
hors du foyer. Aller chercher l’eau aux puits
et fontaines est aussi une tâche exclusivement
féminine comme le suggère l’iconographie,
sans doute plutôt assignée aux esclaves.
Voilà pour un rapide tour d’horizon de la vie
des femmes mariées. Pas forcément trépidant,
mais ce statut matrimonial leur garantit au moins
une protection légale que d’autres n’ont pas.
On exige des épouses grecques la fidélité à
leur mari, les femmes adultères sont exclues
des cérémonies publiques et humiliées, elles
n’ont plus le droit de porter de bijoux sous
peine d’être frappées. Mais pour les hommes,
les relations extraconjugales sont autorisées.
A condition que cela n’ait pas lieu sous son toit,
ni avec l’épouse d’un autre citoyen. La plupart de
ces relations sont tarifées et concernent des
femmes esclaves ou de condition très modeste.
Les prostituées sont dénommées par le
mot de pornai, dérivé du verbe “vendre”,
c’est un terme péjoratif bien qu’elles soient
considérées d’utilité publique. A Athènes,
les lois de Solon au VIe siècle av. J.-C.,
mettent en avant cette utilité pour légaliser
les maisons de passe. Le gouvernement athénien
fait rassembler les prostituées des rues,
et les installe dans des maisons ouvertes à tous,
les dicterions. Cette réforme est conçue comme
une manière de gérer les pulsions des jeunes
gens, et d’éviter qu’ils ne viennent convoiter
les jeunes filles de bonne famille en attente
d’un mariage ou même les femmes déjà mariées.
Les bordels sont donc un moyen de conserver
l’ordre social et de minimiser les sources
de conflit entre citoyens. Le prix de la
passe est réglementé à un tarif très bas,
une obole. Cela permet de rendre ce service
public accessible au plus grand nombre,
et la cité ne se prive pas de prélever
une taxe au passage, le pornikon.
Dans le cadre d’un banquet, la prostitution peut
prendre des formes plus sophistiquées. Musique,
conversation, les femmes sont amenées à
user d’autres charmes, mais là encore,
le service de celles qu’on nomme hétaïres, est
encadré et ne peut pas excéder deux drachmes.
Certains hommes entretiennent aussi une concubine,
qui n’est dès lors plus payée à la passe,
mais salariée en quelque sorte. Dans la haute
société, elles sont traitées avec soin par leur
protecteur pour qui l’entretien d’une « amie de
cœur » est signe ostentatoire de richesse. Le
modèle par excellence est Aspasie, la compagne
de Périclès à qui on a prêté une influence non
négligeable sur le stratège athénien, jusque
dans la conduite de la guerre du Péloponnèse.
Ces concubines et autres femmes monnayant leurs
charmes se devaient de ne pas être enceintes
pour ne pas perdre leur valeur. Les Grecques de
l’Antiquité ne pratiquent pas la contraception
mais ils ont recours à l’avortement, notamment
en sautant de manière répétée et violente pour
faire se décrocher l’embryon. Les femmes le
pratiquent aussi en ingérant des potions aux
propriétés abortives, mais cette méthode est
dangereuse, et beaucoup en meurent empoisonnées
On le voit, qu’elles soient épouses de
citoyen ou de plus basse extraction,
les femmes grecques subissent un modèle patriarcal
rigide. Mineures aux yeux de la loi, les femmes,
même appartenant aux grandes familles, sont
privées des droits les plus élémentaires. Toute
femme est d’ailleurs censée avoir un représentant
légal, un kyrios. Il s’agit du mari, du père,
du frère, ou à défaut, du parent masculin
le plus proche. Ce tuteur se charge des
actes juridiques ou économiques, puisque les
femmes n’ont aucune autonomie en la matière.
Les femmes n’ont par exemple pas la possibilité
d’hériter. A Athènes si un homme meurt en ne
laissant qu’une fille et pas de fils, cette
fille devient épiclère, c’est-à-dire qu’elle
sert de relais au patrimoine jusqu’au
prochain héritier mâle, mais elle n’hérite
pas elle-même. Les proches parents, en particulier
les cousins germains ont alors la priorité pour
l’épouser ce qui est fait pour éviter que le
patrimoine familial ne soit éparpillé. Une
femme mariée devenant épiclère doit donc
divorcer de son mari pour épouser son plus
proche parent mâle et ainsi rapatrier les
biens de son père au sein de la famille.
La loi athénienne interdit par ailleurs aux
femmes de négocier des sommes supérieures à
une médimne d’orge, c’est-à-dire la quantité
nécessaire pour une famille pour une semaine.
Cela leur laisse la possibilité de mener
un petit commerce d’artisanat et de veiller
aux achats du quotidien, mais leur interdit en
revanche la gestion de biens de grande valeur.
Le contrôle des femmes est perceptible jusque
dans l’architecture des maisons grecques. Avec
une entrée unique et une cour intérieure, elles
permettent de surveiller facilement les allées
et venues, en particulier pour éviter que les
femmes de la maison ne soient en contact avec
des hommes venus de l’extérieur. Les femmes
ne sont par exemple pas censées croiser les
compagnons de banquet du chef de famille. Dans
certains contrats de mariage d’époque tardive,
on prévoit par écrit que l’épouse n’a
pas le droit de s’absenter de chez elle,
de jour comme de nuit, sans
l’autorisation de son mari.
L’idéal féminin grec reste en définitive
Pénélope, l’épouse d’Ulysse attendant
sagement son retour pendant vingt ans dans
la plus stricte chasteté. Réclusion, travail
domestique et fidélité, voilà le modèle imposé.
Xénophon l’auteur de l’Economique, un manuel pour
bien tenir son foyer, explique le rôle des
femmes par la nature : « quant à la femme,
la divinité lui a créé un corps moins résistant,
aussi elle me semble l’avoir chargée des travaux
de la maison. » Aristote justifiait lui aussi
les rapports entre hommes et femmes par la
nature : « La relation du mâle à la femelle
est par nature celle de supérieur à inférieur,
de gouvernant à gouverné » (Politiques).
Dans la mythologie même, ce modèle est
énoncé. Le mythe de création de la femme est
raconté par Hésiode dans sa Théogonie. Zeus
fait « fabriquer » Pandora par Héphaïstos pour se
venger du vol du feu par Prométhée : « c’est de
celle-là qu’est sortie la race, l’engeance maudite
des femmes, terrible fléau installé au milieu des
hommes » (Théogonie). Pandora libère tous les
maux sur l’humanité ; et avec elle, la « race
des femmes » oblige les hommes à la reproduction
sexuée, à la naissance et donc à la mort.
Femme = malédiction, une idéologie bien rodée
et qui a persisté bien au-delà de l’Antiquité.
Mais au-delà de ce modèle rigide, les sources
nous font aussi entrevoir une réalité souvent
plus souple. Il ne faut pas oublier que les
textes antiques sont bien souvent normatifs,
c’est-à-dire qu’ils cherchent à énoncer un
modèle, et décrivent la société telle qu’elle
devrait être. Mais on possède aussi des documents
plus discrets, épitaphes funéraires, compte-rendus
de procès ou même dédicaces de monuments.
Ces sources nuancent la vision très fermée
qu’on vient de décrire. Les femmes grecques y
apparaissent par exemple avec un rôle économique
important. Elles sont à la tête d’une
véritable unité de production domestique,
composée de plusieurs esclaves dans les familles
riches. Grâce au produit de leur travail,
qui peut être vendu à l’extérieur, les
femmes participent à la prospérité du foyer.
Le principe de confinement des femmes à
l’intérieur montre lui aussi beaucoup de
limites. C’est sans doute vrai pour les
riches citoyens, mais dans les faits,
la pauvreté abolit les barrières de genre.
Le fond commun méditerranéen penche plutôt
pour une séparation des espaces fréquentés par les
femmes et les hommes, sans doute plus réaliste que
la réclusion décrite par les membres de l’élite.
Dans les foyers pauvres, l’activité des femmes à
l’extérieur est en effet indispensable pour
compléter les revenus du mari. Les femmes
libres vendent donc souvent leurs productions
sur le marché : étoffes, objets d’artisanat,
plantes médicinales, etc. A Athènes, les femmes
de citoyens sont toutefois interdites de vendre
du poisson ou de tenir des bains publics,
des activités qui sont jugées dégradantes.
On a finalement des mentions de femmes ayant
exercé de nombreux métiers. Parmi eux, le métier
de sage-femme est le plus valorisé. Les femmes de
citoyens peuvent le pratiquer sans restriction,
d’autant plus qu’il s’exerce dans l’intimité
d’une maison et pas dans la rue. Phainarété,
la mère de Socrate était elle-même sage-femme.
Certaines en viennent à posséder de véritables
connaissances de médecin gynécologue, c’est
le cas de Phanostratè, femme athénienne connue
grâce à sa stèle funéraire, qui rend hommage
à sa qualité de sage-femme et de médecin.
Dans les milieux modestes, les femmes peuvent
également être employées dans les champs, même
si c’est théoriquement réservé aux hommes. Lors
des récoltes, demandant beaucoup de main-d’œuvre,
la présence des femmes est attestée, notamment
pour le glanage des épis tombés au sol,
un travail particulièrement pénible. Les
campagnes guerrières ayant lieu l’été,
qui est la saison des combats pour
les Grecs, le recours aux femmes
paraît indispensable pour mener à bien les
travaux des champs en l’absence des hommes.
Finalement, il faut bien constater que
les femmes de l’Antiquité grecque nous
apparaissent à travers un miroir déformant.
La grande majorité des sources qui nous sont
parvenues sont d’origine athénienne et ce
prisme est sans doute un peu réducteur. Les
rares fois où l’on possède d’autres sources, de
Sparte, ou de Crète par exemple, elles permettent
souvent de nuancer les pratiques athéniennes
assez rigides. Et il ne faut pas oublier que
les sources souffrent aussi d’un biais social
important. Elles nous parlent un peu des femmes
de citoyens, mais les métèques, c’est-à-dire
les étrangères, et les esclaves sont invisibles.
Par ailleurs, les femmes décrites dans les œuvres
artistiques, dans le théâtre en particulier,
doivent être appréhendées avec un regard critique
car il s’agit de représentations stéréotypées
pour faire ressortir leur caractère comique ou
tragique. D’autant plus que les personnages de
femmes sont joués au théâtre par des hommes, ce
qui conduit à exagérer les stéréotypes de genre.
D’ailleurs pour l’anecdote, les hommes portent
des masques blancs, la couleur de peau des femmes,
qui sont recluses et voient peu le soleil, tandis
que les hommes sont réputés avoir la peau foncée.
Dans les témoignages de justice aussi, les femmes
qui apparaissent dans les affaires familiales
sont cantonnées à des rôles stéréotypés : la bonne
épouse, la maîtresse ingrate, la veuve courageuse,
etc. Là encore, la parole est aux hommes et ne
reflète que les quelques archétypes féminins
communément admis. Même dans l’iconographie
et malgré la diversité des scènes peintes sur
les céramiques par exemple, la figure féminine
reste archétypale. On ne représente jamais les
femmes dans un ouvrage pénible, ni les vieilles
femmes ou encore les mères s’occupant d’enfants
en bas âge. C’est toujours un imaginaire
social de la femme qui se donne à voir.
Chercher un portrait réaliste des
femmes dans les sources masculines
est souvent peine perdue. Cela nous renseigne
toutefois sur le paysage social dans lequel
elles étaient insérées. La cité, ce « club
d’hommes » comme disait Pierre Vidal-Naquet
ne parle finalement des femmes que pour
préciser l’usage qu’en font les hommes.
Il y a en conclusion deux écueils à
éviter : faire des femmes des créatures
totalement soumises au contrôle des hommes et
n’intervenant pas du tout dans la société ; ou
au contraire généraliser les rares exemples
d’émancipation en minimisant le cadre patriarcal.
Cette place attribuée aux femmes et cette
rhétorique de la Grèce d’il y a 2500 ans,
nous la connaissons en fait très bien.
Elle n’est finalement pas très éloignée
de ce qu’on rencontrait encore en Europe au
début du XXe siècle. L’émancipation des femmes
n’a à peine que quelques dizaines d’années,
et encore beaucoup de chemin à parcourir.
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez
mettre un pouce bleus la partager la commenter
donc on a vu aussi la stigmatisation des femmes et
celle de leur sexualité est encore bien présente
dans la majorité des sociétés les nouvelles
technologies ont leur rôle à jouer là-dedans
une application quand même piur permet notamment
aux femmes de décider de leur sexualité comme bon
leur semble d'avoir la responsabilité de leur
corps et des images qu'elle diffuse puis au rap
est une interface qui reste très vigilante
sur le contenu des messages pour permettre
à des gens honnêtes de se rencontrer en toute
bienveillance et c'est pour cette raison qui
m'a semblé intéressant de vous en parler dans
cet épisode je vous remercie je remercie pions
ap de leur confiance vous trouverez sous
la vidéo des informations supplémentaires
sur cette application de rencontre et
moi je vous dis à la prochaine salut